welcome to this video playing hest our
best has the best from Croatia and let's
see let's play kings onion got the
classical main line most are many most
players go for that always surprised how
many adherents this line has okay more
than once i played this very crude
bishop rook f6 rook h6 maneuver and now
try that again okay i think i need to
play this to prevent 95 this whole idea
is rather questionable but it it has
some dangerous points
okay I think he quickly needs to protect
us okay so okay 93 mate what are you
doing now h3 giving up the exchange yeah
like pin so this wasn't too successful
is there something better I mean the
exchange is nice but still let's sign up
the exchange how to continue down this
night a4 b6 still I rather I should
touch it I should control that square
yeah I'm an exchange up but i have a
funny look on age six and so this is
awkward bishop question is should I just
try to convert the material I'll um
continue to attack here probably a
little bit of both and I do one is a
strange woman yes this was was the idea
of this labored it doesn't it doesn't
really threaten much at least that's
what I'm hoping okay peace over
protecting g-form Bishop to da to be six
this would be would be excellent and I'm
trying for that Bishop dhb six would
improve my bishop from being the worst
piece of the board to being one of the
best pieces huh can really do that
probably
can exchange it it's let's exchange the
rock this is a really his most active
piece not sure that this is the best
move but let's get let's get rid of the
rook the night does it have any great
moves I don't think so it would it's a
discover truth attacking the knight on a
750 moves f2 but I think I can just drop
back note that the rukon g6 is always
protecting DC so this piece is actually
a fulfilling a useful role so how and
how to continue now probably I can get
maybe I can get a 5 now he didn't
protect it next move I can take it and
it's not the pawn that the issue is that
after getting getting this this one I am
I actually get this great square so
g-form now takes tags real let's go g4
what's the best move now probably first
to take here
hmm actually overlooked that he can just
recapture with the bishop it's not
particularly great I mean it's probably
enough but it's it's not what I what I
wanted to do hmm yeah this is annoying
check him no Queen B 6 getting rid of
the Queen's check okay it's it's still
in an exchange up I would have liked of
course to continue the attack but this
is not bad at all I've got a healthy
structure and it's an extra exchange
maybe night yeah yeah let's let's play
actively he can take it but
mmm didn't didn't see that
I need to get the look into the game
Rock g8 and something I needed needed
badly on the queenside try to to pick up
the beep on at the end
check yep i need you i need to take it
okay
Oh
I didn't didn't take that into account
at all now it's not necessarily the end
of the world but I didn't see the move
at all no f6 coming oh
check
f g4 covered Wow but the crazy position
time warning
and don't own 30 seconds and what the
egg
unbelievable game no I'm busted young
the two points promote can you believe
that yeah why did I screw this up g4
already was a was terrible I don't I
only have checks in black for effects on
time just a couple of checks it so he
can play and it's nothing nothing going
on how why did I screw this up when G
foam already was was terrible to allow
that maybe I'm okay of course I should
probably not many not exchange Queens
but it is certainly a winning position I
lost a bit of time here but chatted
still yeah this should be completely
over yeah it's a minus five position
I can actually take check because of
rook a 30 this is this isn't even
difficult oh damn of course then it's
it's a very easy win if I can take now
on g3 this okay it's still winning but
getting getting tricky check yeah I know
it's lost now it's lost after g6 Wow
yeah okay had many ways to to win it but
I didn't I didn't figure it out also
yeah maybe g-form yeah yeah then g4 also
isn't the most precise I've just an
exchange up here for foot bed for
basically nothing I can easily even
improve my position I miscalculated the
sacrifice on g4 him yeah what can you do
if you don't win with an exchange up for
nothing it's a your fault yeah thanks
for watching